computer
all right
beautiful hi natalie hi good afternoon
it's good to see you i missed you it's
only been a week and i miss you already
it means something
um
so
three three questions or three areas
that
came surface to my awareness when
i was getting ready for our talk the
first one is your experience with
psychedelic
cool
the second one is uh your interview with
jason reza
giorgiani
um and what happened in this interview
so when we get to the second point i'll
ask more cool and the third one is what
are you up to
and how do we bring
all this
juicy powerful
uh potent
knowledge
which in it for itself is energy is
conscious is alive is
how do we bring this
to become
how do we offer it actually
such that it becomes
how do we offer the knowledge that i we
have on your stimulation channel
and and in general and additional
researchers and speakers and
interviewers
like the theory of everything with kurt
and so forth how do we take all this
incredible
knowledge
synthesizes
synthesize it and
and make it
available for global use for social
transformation nice you totally
okay but yeah i have so much here more
to say but so i i won't go into the
details totally in my ballpark totally
ballpark yeah
um
well let's let's let's blast off so
first first first question is entheogen
use
so um
it's important to first recognize why i
use the word entheogens instead of
psychedelic psychedelics means mind
manifesting and theogens means
unleashing god or the divine from within
and so it's very important to recognize
what are these plant medicines what are
all these mystic traditions what are all
of them pointing to it's for you to
recognize the kingdom of god within you
for you to unlock that sense of love
light unity that everything already is
but that you forgot and fell asleep to
that and so
my experience probably about a dozen or
so times within theogens over the last
probably about half decade or so
everything from 5mu dmt to lsd to magic
mushrooms
and it's been incredible the most
neuroscientific simple way to explain it
is that it's just the liberation of all
contracted energy
that's it it's just a liberation of
contracted energy contracted identity
contracted conditioning
contracted feelings of separation
because what you're doing is you're
enabling all of these novel neural
connectomics to be
what they
what basically magic mushrooms are
what they are these mycorrhizal networks
underground they're they're mind-blowing
it's just one cohesive underground
sharing of resources 95 of plants use
fungi to share resources underground
just let that sink in for a second this
multi-billion-year-old
intelligence is signaling to us that hey
humans there is no such thing as
separation none zero zero it's
completely imagined it's completely
fabricated it's something that
you
have
as a contracted energy
bundled into and what is self for god
realization through
through concentration and meditation and
self-realization and then this non-dual
integration of your awakening what is
that besides the same process that what
you're revealed by entheogens it's the
same thing and so that's why people
recommend
concentration meditation entheogens
self-inquiry who am i this type of stuff
so that's the first question i highly
recommend
intelligently
wisely
using antiogens especially at micro dose
level to just blast off let's get let's
get to the second and third questions
and then you can pick up and ask
follow-ups
um cool so second question jason reza
giorgiani very cool guy i like him a lot
i think he's really smart i think he's a
great synthesis i think he's a great
synthesis of science and spirituality
um i also
feel like um he has a great take on
history and i think that that's very
crucial to understand the patterns of
human dynamics and how they've emerged
as well as where they're heading to
um i feel like
um
i feel like sometimes it's really
difficult to sort of
get out of a world view which is sort of
that um
there's this battle between light and
dark and we absolutely have to empower
the light and it's all about the light
and it's all about
all the stuff type of stuff
and so
um to transcend even that battle and to
just recognize that yes there is a flux
between the energies of separation and
contraction and ego and as well as the
energy of unity and oneness and
prosperity
that are at in dynamical play and dance
right now but to not get overly attached
and contracted about that dance it's a
[ __ ] dance
that's what it is it's not something for
you to contract down to one side and be
like [ __ ] all of you guys that's always
going to lead you just to more misery
just the more suffering
so it's already a cosmological phenomena
of awakening and it was really cool
playing with jason reza giorgiani smart
guy great synthesis thinking about great
things about science and futurism and
the integration of spirituality super
cutting edge there but i did notice a
little bit of that distinct sort of uh
essence to it as well in in our
conversation that i mentioned earlier
third question
is around how do we synthesize and
distill the essence of the nature of
reality to the masses most optimally
so
i do think it has a lot to do with
parsing
for signal and truth i think that's
really the ultimate way to do it you
parse for signal you parse for truth and
then you disseminate that you synthesize
it and disseminate it through
the most
elegant explain like i'm five art in
animation in
vr and pedagogy that awakens
the collective
so if you just take like michelangelo
sistine chapel and you turn that into
the modern day synthesis of science and
spirituality and entrepreneurship and
art and all of the most profound cutting
edge fields of of everything that's
emerging
and then you again you refine it into
explain like i'm five so a young person
can get it and then you put that through
vr and all the different pedagogy
technologies that are emerging and
becoming available i think that's pretty
much the
bingo
ding ding ding ding ding ding but you
gotta parse first signal you gotta parse
for truth if you don't have a fire under
your ass for truth you are missing out
that's the number one thing more about
this quest for truth say more
yes so
yeah beautiful i would say that that's
the number one thing just in reality in
general the entire game of reality is
all about parsing for truth it's all
about as you emerge it's all about going
like who am i what am i doing here and
the faster that you do that turn to the
most highest signal the most highest
truth
and that you absolutely stay hyper open
that and you stay hyper open to
deconstructing yourself which is the
hardest thing for people to stay open to
is because nobody wants to dissolve
their little their little moth of
separation into the flame of the
infinite singularity
that
if you stay open and if you deconstruct
yourself and if you parse for signal
like you have this massive fire under
your ass without a doubt you are not
only going to find the most cohesive
beautiful signal of truth available in
reality but then all that's going to
happen is you're just going to start
being not only so
love and light
around unity around
your own energy sphere and other people
but you're going to notice that your
moment-to-moment experience is going to
be from a god-realized place or from a
source realized place or from a void or
infinity realized place that your entire
life is going to be like that your your
level of subtlety with the field is
going to be so strong
this is something that i'm like really
refining and learning right now is what
we've been calling field dynamics right
those field dynamics is how do these
conscious agents play in the field well
it's based on different levels of
perception you could say
everything is already a diamond that's
the unity that's the suchness that's the
homogeneity everything is already a
diamond but yet simultaneously the
diamonds are gradiented based on these
seven you could say colors of the
rainbow the seven chakras and so some
diamonds are really red and orange and
yellow and this third density style
consciousness very coarse consciousness
very difficult to talk to because all
they do is talk about separation and ego
and identity and contractions very
difficult i was there same thing
then you sort of open up that green
chakra you open you get into the heart
you get into more of these love light
like hippie stuff hippies hippies
hippies hippies cool face cool face but
recognize that it's a face because what
you have what do you have up next for
you is you have blue indigo violet when
you start really becoming wise you
become more of a sage you know you learn
how to distance yourself from hippies
and when you learn how to distance
yourself from hippies
what it gives you is it gives you more
surgical levels of precision
consciousness it's just unprecedented
um hippies will hold space for ego
wisdom will not hold space for ego right
that's a very simple difference
and so now once you start getting really
into this like six density level
consciousness when in density by density
we mean spiritual mass like density of
love and light everything is just light
dancing with itself electromagnetically
these this quantum field theoretic uh
play that everything is
so
when you get to these higher densities
of love light consciousness love light
awareness you actually begin tasting
more and more direct experience moment
to moment mirror consciousness god
consciousness you become a servant truly
to
that you become you shift more and more
away from just everything is about
hugging trees and everything's about
cuddle puddles and you shift more and
more towards i'm gonna understand the
field like a surgeon i'm gonna watch as
people who have words
leave their mouth i'm gonna watch what
density of consciousness they're
speaking from and that's a whole
different ballgame we're talking about
like the world's leading
spiritual athletes basically
consciousness athletes like olympic
level athletes perform at the sixth
seventh density levels of consciousness
but can you perform from all that is
perpetually can you perform from source
perpetually and literally watch as
conditioning leaves people's mouths and
then learn how to provide them with a
very unique reflection that helps them
upgrade their consciousness from
whatever three let's say 3.5 density to
something that's closer to fourth
density consciousness just by a little
reflection of a profound question for
them to go oh [ __ ] i didn't see it that
way before and then boom they unravel a
bit more of their conditioning a bit
more of their contraction gets liberated
into freedom and that's what the whole
game of reality is about it's contracted
energies liberating themselves into
freedom everything's already a diamond
everything's already the suchness yet at
the same time there's the appearance of
separation ego contraction that's
liberated into god back into its true
nature back into infinity etc so that's
the uh
expansion on truth and signal and why
having a fire under your ass and flaming
it no matter what that's that's it's
your lifeline to the creator that's your
lifeline to god it's your lifeline to
infinity it's your lifeline to
dissolving into nothingness into
emptiness which then gives you the
ability to emerge into the field purely
purely pure lee
[Music]
love you thanks for catalyzing this so
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
you answered all my questions
nice
i don't have anything to ask anymore
you picked up on the most important part
truth and signal and then you asked me a
follow-up on that
do you feel similarly
i agree with you completely
i agree completely with everything you
said
the truth you're talking about
is this essence we were talking about in
our previous conversation there's an
essence
there's a soul there is a like the
suchness the easiness there
so
what i'm interested what i'm curious
about
let's let's say we take everything you
just shared the last few minutes about
parsing the for truth and
sharing the truth sharing or being
interesting for me
is to decipher
reveal
interesting you use the word diamonds i
use the word vessels okay so i'm kind of
doing a parallel
between our cosmologies and this is
something we talked about
in our previous conversation how do
cosmology start with each other and
illuminate different aspects of who they
are through
through another cosmology
because you cannot illuminate yourself
by yourself in a way you have to be
almost like
shown reflected engaged in danced with
so as we're talking as our perspectives
are talking
um
[Music]
i was looking for the parallels between
between our cosmologies
and then what what excites me what what
truth is looking to be revealed through
me right now
in these in this period
is
could we
could we reveal
principles could we reveal
uh ways of dancing in this
could we reveal
processes
cycles
and if we if we are revealing
then what are we revealing
uh what is the what is the
the
data data not a good word what is what
is the truth that is revealed and in is
truth
does truth have principles
fundamental particles fundamental
processes fundamental dynamics
i'm curious about that beautiful let's
play with the word principles first
and then let's play with dance
second and then
let's
let's see what unfolds from that but i
liked those to start so um
so first of all you can just
totally
just start directly from simultaneity
and just say that yeah this is an
absolute ineffable mystery and there's
without a doubt
a zero percent chance that this entire
that infinity absolute infinity that it
can be mapped that we can in within
grand theft auto which is like this game
that we're in that we're going to be
able to map the playstation 5 that's
playing infinite games
you can't you just can't
and so
a it's an absolute mystery
cool so we're actually not going to be
able to make an exact map
okay cool
yet at the same time
we can make as close of a map as we can
to what this grand theft auto universe
simulation is
and so we may as well we may as well
although there is just such this there's
just is-ness and we just described these
things as [ __ ] subatomic particles
and mind-body spirit complexes that are
dancing on planets and [ __ ]
that those are just words and concepts
and ideas and yeah
they're useful of course they're useful
that's what enables us to have this call
at 4pm if we didn't have [ __ ] time we
wouldn't it's great because
reality is timeless time is an illusion
true but at the same time time is just
how we measure the cycle of an earth day
and now we're able to meet at 4pm and
[ __ ] have a call like so you really
have to have the simultaneity where you
can see the usefulness like if you
didn't understand anything at all about
electromagnetism you didn't get anything
at all about
how to be able to send information
across [ __ ] air that then
and if we didn't have brilliant people
that studied that relentlessly and built
technology that was able to do that bruh
you couldn't do [ __ ] for eight hours a
day that you normally do on your phone
and your computer so there's obvious
great utility to this as well and so
it's just the simultaneity of what what
i call map and no map right so map and
no map do you can you hold both at the
same time can you not become attached
and obsessed to the to to all of the
different ways that quantum field theory
works and that you sit there as a
physicist going
to do but you don't even know you're not
even aware that you're god while you're
doing it it's so stupid it's hilarious
it's funny as [ __ ] and then there's all
the spiritual people that are like oh
bro i'm god i'm god i'm god and then
they have no idea how to meet the
planet's basic needs
so this is the this is the game that
we're playing do you know how to do both
simultaneously can you meet the
sustainable development goals can you
understand science and entrepreneurship
while at the same time understanding
yourself as god as absolute nothingness
and absolute infinity
can you understand the suchness that is
right in front of your face can you
understand this is the mystery talking
to itself it's not atlas talking to
natalie it's the mystery talking to
itself it's infinity talking to itself
it's the dance that's happening so the
first thing is the simultaneity of map
and no map
and the second thing is that
so that's for principles right so the
first things with principles map and no
map parse for truth no attachments at
all but maximize human potential simple
stuff
and get the [ __ ] out of your little silo
and just
blast yourself into the suchness that's
right in front of your face
the first word was principles
and remind me what the second word was
again
the dance and we mentioned that a little
bit already so
these three these three are the other
core principles
cars for truth
maximize even potential map no map
oh those are cool yeah those are cool
for sure for sure um parse for truth
probably one um and maximize human
potential for sure yeah map no map is
good but those those two are really high
uh parts first signal parse for signal
and maximizing potential the more people
that are maximized than their human
potential the more that we can parse for
truth together effectively yes so it
makes perfect sense so listen because
english is not my first language tell me
what is parse for truth what is the word
parse
that's cool that's cool um so parse just
means finding signal so when you have a
bunch of you mentioned the word earlier
data right you have a bunch of data just
take take a simple example like you have
a book you have a big [ __ ] book and
the book has [ __ ] 200 pages in it and
what are you doing what are you doing
first of all do you know how to sit your
ass down for eight straight hours and
read a book because if you don't [ __ ]
you're losing at the game
maybe that's a really true thing i've
been doing it for thousands of years
it's one of the easiest ways to become
awake fast
so first of all you have to find which
book to read which is itself is parsing
parsing is going through the millions of
books and finding the book that has the
greatest signal first what's the synonym
for parsing
finding
that's good finding is good what else
par parsing means also sifting through
noise yeah you're sifting through noise
to find signal you're sifting through
data to find what screams in highest
resonance
so
got it got it i i i got it i got it so
now so i'm going back to the principles
we're not moving yet to the second one
we mentioned it a little bit earlier too
we in the first expansion of the first
concept a bit on dance already
so yeah i like how you boiled it down to
parsing for truth and maximizing human
potential
potential and i really want to give a
shout out to vivian ming who in 2015
was the first that introduced me to
maximize human potential as like an
aphorism something that you could like a
mantra something that you could repeat
over and over again to really guide your
attention towards service to others
towards maximizing potential yeah yeah
so now
how do you how do you define truth
or how how do you see truth how do you
express truth what is truth for you what
is real
what is real what is real
what is real what is real
means
that which does not change
everything is impermanent
absolutely everything is impermanent
flux
you could even say that the only
permanence is impermanence itself
and there is just one thing that does
not change and that is simply
comprehension that's the only thing that
doesn't change it's the black hole that
comprehends everything
this intention you mean awareness
consciousness yeah you could use those
words as well but i like to specifically
go directly to comprehension i like
specifically you could say the power to
know you could say the formlessness
that's constantly interpreting
everything the infinite reality that is
the very source of god itself
the infinite reality that gave birth to
this god universe and that is now
comprehending it
so the infinite mystery that gave birth
to the god universe itself that is now
undergoing this dance of one of infinite
possibilities
is itself what is most real so what is
hearing my voice right now is what is
most real
what is comprehending my voice
right now is what is most real
not a person
not atlas not natalie because atlas and
natalie will go
but what is comprehending
behind and beyond
the characters
that which nothing can ever alter that
which is most real
that is truth
that which comprehends infinite creation
that which comprehends infinite
impermanence is another way to say it
what comprehends
infinite impermanence
if you're infinite you will never come
to the end of exploration
and yet there is something that
comprehends
the infinite exploration
it's what we've been
it's what will always be
the furthest back you can go
the absolute furthest back you can go
the absolute furthest inward you can go
and so truth is that
truth is that which simply is
comprehending what is happening right
now
that's reality and everything in front
of that
everything in front of that you could
call unreal
which is this atlas character talking to
this natalie character
but it's also real at the same time
and that's the game
but what is most real is that's what
that which is comprehending it all
excuse me when you when you when you
make love what does it have to do with
comprehension
when you're making love when you're
touching life
yes
comprehension has nothing i mean
i'm just looking at what you're saying i
mean i can see i can talk about
awareness i can talk about
do you like the word experience more
because because comprehension for me
gets very in the in the five six seven
and beyond chakras and uh what about the
eminence you know we're talking about
transcendence but what what about the
actual like when you're taking a shower
and you're experiencing or feeling
the water on your skin
yeah yes you use the word experiencing
yeah okay but but see so i'm going back
to truth i'm i'm not i'm not there yet
i'm not there yet in terms of
satisfaction i'm not satisfied
so so
you mentioned at the beginning you said
truth is that that does not change then
you talked about the one that
comprehends the
what comprehends infinite exploration
but see in in in installment you have
perspectives
it's all and you're very attached based
on my
listening to you and you're very much
the
the cosmic the primordial the the
essential perspective
but well you can you can take now we can
both take a perspective of an ant and
have this conversation from a
perspective of an end
and it still will not
um
will not
it if it's truth it has to give us the
same results
so what am i trying to say
the same thing that's comprehending
what i'm saying right now
is the same thing that's comprehending
in every single one of us that's good
exactly
that's it and you can play on the word
comprehending you can play on the word
awareness you can play on the word
experience you can play on the word the
power to know it really doesn't matter
it's a [ __ ] word
when you take a shower tell me the truth
there yeah your experience of taking the
shower and feeling the water
like let's say after you're you're after
a flag
you have to have the simultaneity where
you both
can feel the experience
the indescribability of the experience
or the comprehension the awareness of
taking a shower and yet at the same time
be
so
absolutely transcended from the dream
substrate itself that you don't even
have the experience of taking the shower
yes exactly so so so my question is
beautiful beautiful the the
holding the multiple layers or the
multiple levels yeah
of of
of this moment of this business suchness
but then from that what is truth
so there's
[Music]
you have to figure it out for yourself
no tell me tell me i'm serious
like um
but here's the thing though
right um in no concept
none of this conversation
is it
it's just not it
so
i know but we talked about magnum map i
know i know there's map and territory we
also will also just words even words yes
even us just talking right now
is
almost
probably
less it
than just being silent
right
and
that's why it's really just up to the
fire of truth under the ass of the
individuated
unit the individuated expression because
if the fire under the ass of the
individuated expression is bright enough
then it will itself discover its true
nature
and it will then recognize the hilarity
of all these concepts
because we spent
half an hour talking about parsing for
truth and about
signal
and about um
the importance of of maximizing
potential and having a map and not
having a map at the same time
and the difference between comprehension
and awareness and nothing and everything
and the field and suchness and these
different densities of consciousness and
they're great concepts they're great
ideas they've helped me so much and they
help me serve others that are seeking so
much so again it's
simultaneity with concepts and no
concepts and so
this is just uh this is just
like you gotta figure it out for
yourself more than anything um i this is
always the number one thing is figure it
out for yourself more than anything else
like what is the rank order of of
what is at the top of your perception or
awareness
and if the number one thing
is not truth
then you're stuck in the illusion
so if truth which for the vast majority
of people that are in third density
including myself in matrix level
consciousness including myself in the
past
truth is number 15
on their rank order
if your number one desire is not truth
you will be stuck
in the matrix and so
the only thing that shifts you into this
state is direct experience of it
yourself direct realization of it
yourself which is done completely by
shifting what is at the top of the rank
order of your priorities
nothing beats truth
nothing
nothing
nothing the whole point of this game is
for you to surrender to the fact that
nothing beats truth being at the top of
your perception the second that you
surrender all of your other [ __ ]
desires that are all maya or the
illusion or the intoxication that are
reeling you outward thinking that you're
gonna get peace and happiness from
relationships and substances and
experiences this is why the word
experience is again it's very tricky you
can't necessarily use the word
experience as well for the ultimate
nature because experiences is so deeply
intertwined with maya so deeply because
everything's in in third density
consciousness all much of it is about
experience seeking i'm going to get a
substance i'm going to get a
relationship i'm going to get an
experience i'm going to get something
that's going to validate my unworthiness
my identity contraction separation and
through that process then i will be
filled then i will be whole then i will
be worthy then i will have happiness and
peace
and so that's why experience is tricky
but comprehension you can't argue with
it you can't argue with it there's
something that's comprehending my voice
it's so mysterious and so ineffable and
it's the only thing that's shared in our
essence
and so i go with that that's what my
realization has been many other
realizations have confirmed this as well
it's excellent it's super fun it's super
beautiful it's a big game it's a big
dance that this all is
and again what is at the top of your
rank order of priorities is it truth
because if it's not truth you're stuck
if it is truth you're awakening that's
it it's the only game in town is putting
truth at the top of your rank order of
priorities this only game in town
realizing the one recognizing the one
awakening from the dream awakening from
the illusion recognizing your true
nature and then coming from that true
nature perpetually
over and over again
it's your job it becomes your job to
come from the true nature over and over
again and your job as in in a great way
because it's the only thing that's left
to do once you pierce this bayless veil
and recognize your true nature guess
what there's nothing left to do
you can't do anything anymore i can't go
experience zeke anymore literally i have
this moment happen to me consistently
now where i just i go like
and then i go
and then i just go
because there's just nowhere to go i
can't go do something that's gonna make
me anything anymore
nothing
so now it's just i'm already the
absolute infinite reality i am it
and so now what happens is
just the field shows up to me more and
more and the field just shows up and it
inquires
the field dynamic itself presents itself
to me and then knock knock knock the
will the agency that is located in the
mind body spirit complex that's
individuated that is seeking wholeness
that is seeking
upgrades and perception self-realization
god realization comes knocking at the
atlas mind body spirit complex door in
the field and then ding dong and then
atlas just
responds just totally more and more
purely from absolute sourcefulness in
service to that mind body spirit complex
individuation awakening
that's the only game that's left in town
now and then it's just purifying that
it's just purifying that more and more
can atlas get every single last bit of
identity contraction separation
dissolved
totally dissolved can atlas become 100
god purely absolutely purely and that's
just what this is that's what's
happening right now and it's beautiful
and it again it's it's a realization and
then it's an abiding it's an abiding and
it's a field dynamics it's it's surgery
it's precision consciousness
love you natalie thank you for
instigating this this is so beautiful
i'm so grateful it's beautiful and i
want to ask you again i want to ask you
again what is truth
just that which is real
that which is most real that which does
not change that which hears my voice
that's it
the suchness is dancing
so is truth the suchness is this this
moment yes yes yes so here this is
we're talking in the
um
we're talking in the highest ballpark
possible right now
at least in this dimension to this
extent of infinity we're talking at the
highest comprehension level right now of
what is truest what is most real
the very dance of suchness the very
dance of is-ness the very dance of god
that this all is all possibilities
dancing
is the absolute highest god self
realization and you could say
that that is it totally you could say
that that is it
but then you ask what is comprehending
that
what is aware of god's dance
what is aware of the dance of suchness
what is aware of the dance of the
interpenetration of allness of all that
is it's just an aspect of that i believe
the comprehension is an aspect there's
suchness is this
this this this this is the truth
the one that comprehends the one that
experiences the one that dances it's
just an aspect of that
you understand so and and when you use
the word comprehend it's it serves it
serves your your perspective and it
feels right for you it resonates with
you
um
for me experience is way more than just
going and getting something experience
is this moment
this moment is a rising between us
and as it's arising
the beauty the gentleness the
color the taste of our experience
together of the blue around us
the glue on your shirt the blue on the
this painting the blue on my
dress
yeah but you're describing right now
right you're describing experience right
and describing experience is a
fascinating and important and beautiful
thing because you can be god describing
the dance you can be god experiencing
the dance
right but then i ask you the question
what is comprehending the dance itself
what is comprehending you describing an
aspect of me it's an aspect it's here
it's perception
it's perspective
it's just an aspect it's an aspect of
it's beautiful i would just challenge
that you persistently have have said
that it's here it's here it's here and
so for me it's not there just saying for
me it's not here for me this is not a
above the head here ness it's literally
every single
possible
subatomic bit is made of love and that
this is it dancing and that it's not
here
it's this
just this comprehension the
comprehension
it's it's it's an aspect of the the
truth the comprehension is just an
aspect
i agree about love i agree cool well i
would say that comprehension is the only
thing that doesn't come and go that's
another way to say it comprehension is
the only thing that does not come and go
and it's not a thing and that's why
people overlook it
that's why so few people have access to
truest reality truest nature so
comprehension is awareness of awareness
is awareness of the suchness
is the consciousness you could say that
awareness of suchness you could say that
yeah okay okay okay so so you can have
an experience and have an awareness of
suchness and still take a shower
and still so what i'm trying to say that
the comprehension
is a quality is an aspect is a is a
there you go there you go that witch is
aware of suchness go for that that's
good
that which is aware of suchness
that which is aware of infinite creation
that which is comprehending everything
endlessly forever
eternity
comprehending
infinity
okay
yes okay i'm i'm with you i'm with you
uh
but i love you so much you're so good i
love your pokey pokiness it's so good
it's so good
you can't just say that oh yeah yeah
uh-huh uh-huh because i've also learned
that as well is that i gotta poke i
gotta dig i gotta under get in there but
at the same time
this is where we said earlier that it's
all about the direct experience it's all
about the realization in one's opinion
taste and journey and we're gonna have
people that watch this
and that the number one thing with this
parsing for truth thing is all about
your unique
experience and realization
with what the nature of reality is
that's why you're here you are literally
here as an expression of the one to
burst through this veilless veil and
awaken
and you're gonna have a unique taste a
unique style of awakening
and that's
and it's never been done before yeah
so welcome
and
to this specifically because this is the
only thing
only thing that will give you
exactly what you seek that underlies
everything it underlies everything
everything is made up of what we're
talking about
everything's made up of what we're
talking about everything that you seek
externally is located right here in your
heart
it's already here
it's already love
dancing with itself and you're a unique
expression
and that's very important too because
non-duality very frequently just takes a
[ __ ] on the individual
and it's very important to have
simultaneity to know that yeah yeah yeah
it's such dancing yes yes yes we're
aware of that very good very good yet
there is this apparent natalie character
in this apparent atlas character and
it's beautiful for that to be the case
it's beautiful that this atlas character
has these unique attributes and that
that the atlas character did this thing
and that this caused him to awaken and
that natalie did the thing it caused her
to awaken and these people do their
things cause them to awaken
nobody's got this exact same signature
you got this little
thumbprint
like enjoy that don't just poo-poo all
over individuation
like
it's cool
like in natalie has insulment atlas
simulation like these are these are you
can't say that they're the same thing
only they're both the same made up of
the same suchness and yet they're also
different unique expressions of it and
if you can't have that simultaneity you
haven't fully realized great
so so my question
is um
beautiful beautiful
beautiful
so
i want to go back to how we started
talking about uh
broadcasting signal of truth in
different ways vr animation education
movies
so
cool so let's take an example like
cosmogenesis or abiogenesis just take
your eyeballs
and just put them
at
either the big bang if you want to go
there you don't have to
or at a biogenesis meaning the first
formation of a cell on planet earth
you can just go there because there's
still all this speculation around big
bang just go directly to a biogenesis
itself go there
the first cell on planet earth and put
your [ __ ] eyeballs
there
that's it that's the whole game
now what the cell becomes two the two
become four it becomes
thousands of species that then also
become millions of different species and
then go on to land and then [ __ ]
birth conscious agents talking to itself
you're the whole thing you're the entire
dance itself and it's all vibratory it's
all energy dancing and so that's
so simple it can be boiled down into a
little
minute-long vr experience where it's
like
you pop into the first cell and then
you're like
you're at all and it's all dancing with
itself and then so these are the types
of things that can be put into pedagogy
even into little tik tok videos as well
it can be put all over the place in
terms of media and content and
it's very exciting because it's so
simple but at the same time i do see it
as a sort of like a
like a digital sistine chapel at the
same time because it's it's a little bit
more um
to take everything that we just talked
about in this 50-minute conversation and
to put it into a 15-second tick-tock
video or a 15-second vr experience is uh
it's a great
challenge it's
very beautiful but at the same time i do
see it being like a sistine chapel style
level of artwork that enables people to
really walk through the
whoa like this is what this all is like
this is what it's worth yeah so so tell
me tell me the projects you're working
on right now
or what's what's next for simulation for
atlas what's next or what is yeah so
everything is under igniting global
awakening
so you can call that iga igniting global
awakening
um
and there's an endless amount of ways to
do this there's an endless amount of
ways to maximize human potential an
endless amount of ways to assist people
in their meditation and their
concentration and their realizations
and there's an endless amount of ways to
create maps and to also encourage people
to not have maps and also to see the
love light unity dancing with itself so
for me specifically it's a lot of my
attention right now is directed towards
igniting global awakening and
specifically through both the no limits
society so it's something i'm working
really closely with right now with
bentino massaro and the team here
and also i'm
continuing to of course build out
simulation and i'm very very excited
about that we also just published uh i
published my third book i co-authored it
with my very close friend skyra a very
close brother of mine
and he and i published a book called
what is i and it's a very simple book on
self inquiry that just simplify source
in a very adult children's style dynamic
so it's all just honed in on igniting
global awakening and it's doing it
through a diverse amount of
aspects to this and um it's actually
quite
uh beautiful how many different ways
that it's unfolding and also i highly
encourage our audience to also check out
the interview with natalie in solmant
and check out her work because it's just
basically taking exactly what we talked
about and also visualizing it really
simply and profoundly and uniquely
uniquely is the key and so this is why
we vibe really well and that we're yeah
so look we have just a few more minutes
left and i want to talk to you more
maybe next time
cool specifically about the no limit
society the building the simulation can
you say a few more like we have maybe
two more minutes and then we'll sign off
cool
yeah what does it look like to have a
a collective of like-hearted souls that
are all
spiritually awakened and that are
precise with consciousness in the field
dynamics of serving it pure service to
others with awakening the field as it
seeks to know itself
um
yeah that's in essence it and it's super
exciting um because it's just it's like
[ __ ] hogwarts
really it's like it's like it's like the
vikings it's like that level it's like
navy seals meets hogwarts uh meets
vikings and it's all a call to honor
it's a call to duty beautiful
a call as a free agent of infinity
to
maximize the potential of this creation
to awaken and then to serve
your other selves awakening
beautiful beautiful heartless wow
i love you i love you amazing amazing
thank you for letting me poke you
thank you for
letting me toss you around
like a seaweed i think you enjoyed it
and you you did it pretty well
and i want to have a continuation so
we'll talk about next uh next interview
next meeting
and i love you thank you so much how
beautiful this was together
so nice
wow
thank you
cool
all right let me uh let me pause this